we continue our discussion of the US
Iran war that is happening right now.
So um as you know I made the prediction
that the United States will lose this
war and last class we did an overview of
the military and strategic position
and today we're going to provide some
theoretical framework for how to
understand
how this war will progress and why
ultimately I believe the United States
will lose this war. Today I present to
you a very important idea in game
theory. And once you understand this
idea, then you understand
why things will turn out the way they
do. Okay? It's called a law of
asymmetry. Okay? Law of asymmetry.
And all this is saying is that
the United States and Iran are not
peers. They're not equals. United States
is far stronger than Iran. And we should
expect the United States to overwhelm
and destroy Iran really easily. But the
law of asymmetry states that that's
usually not the case. It's usually the
underdog that has the advantage
and we see this from history all the
time. Okay. So when the Persians in
about 490 BC invaded mainland Greece
against Athens and Sparta, Persia at
this at that time was the first world
empire. It had infinite resources,
infinite manpower, infinite wealth, and
it lost to the Greeks not once but
twice. And and then the Macedonians
under ex the Greek and they were like a
tribal army, not a very large army. They
were able to go into Persia and Persia
at the time was basically most of
Eurasia and conquered [snorts] it in
about 10 years time.
The Romans started off as a tribal
people which then built the
Mediterranean Empire.
Then you have the Aztecs. You have so
the Vikings. So this happens a lot in
human history. A people in the
borderlands, a tribe, a small ethnicity
are able to conquer a great empire. And
the law of asymmetry tells us why. Okay.
So, I'm going to go over uh very slowly
in detail how this law symmetry
asymmetry works. [snorts] All right. So,
um let's look at an empire.
And there are three major advantages to
an empire. All right. The first is mass.
This just means that they have a lot of
people. Okay? They almost have an
infinite amount of people. United States
has a population of about 350 million
people. But remember the United States
can also draw on the populations of its
allies which includes the five eyes, the
angles but also includes Europe. It also
includes uh East Asia, South Korea,
Japan. Basically wherever the Americans
have a military base, right? So most of
the world are either allies of the
United States or vassels of the United
States. So the United States can
basically draw on in billions and
billions of people for its wars. Okay.
So it's mass. Second is this idea of
organization.
Organization just means a hierarchy of
bureaucracy
scientific technology. Okay. Science and
technology.
which leads to the most advanced
weaponry. Okay, so think about the
United States, how they fight this war.
They have these satellites that provide
for precision targeting. They have these
um airplanes, these B2 bombers, F-15s
that are the most advanced
um weaponry ever in human history. Okay,
so organization. The last
great strength of the empire is that he
of death.
Death is the idea that because your
people are infinite, because your
organization is so strong, because your
resources are so vast, you can afford to
lose many, many wars. Okay? It's not a
big deal. United States loses this war
in Iran. If they want to go back, they
can go back with even more soldiers,
even more um weaponry because their
wealth is infinite.
Okay, so these are the three major
advantages of an empire. And in theory,
because of these advantages, an empire
should be invincible and eternal. But we
know for a fact that all empires fall
and they fall very, very hard. And quite
honestly, they don't last a very long
time. maybe 28 years, maybe 300 years
for most empires. That's not a very long
time. So, we need to better understand
what's going on. Okay. Why is it that an
empire with these vast resources, they
all fall in 20 years, 30 years. Okay.
All right. So, um
what we need to understand is that all
these advantages are ultimately
disadvantages in the long term. All
right. Right? So let let me explain what
I mean. Match you have a lot of people.
Okay? When you have a lot of people, you
create a lot of inequality.
Why? Because there's competition for
resources. There's too many people.
Okay? And this often leads to debt and
slavery.
And as a result, your people become
complacent, lazy, indifferent. They're
competing against each other. They
really don't like the government. Okay?
So, they're not that really that
motivated
to do anything to work or to fight wars,
but especially to fight wars. So, this
mass looks like looks like an advantage
in the beginning, but over time it
becomes a disadvantage. Right?
Organization
um means an elite. The problem with this
is that over time the elite become
parasites.
Why? Because the way the way they make
their money is through rent seeking.
Rentseeking just means that you have
power and you seek to monetize your
power by exploiting the mass.
All right. So basically landlords
are a classic type of ransicking elite
and so they don't really work but they
make a lot of money because they own the
land because they control all the
resources because they control all the
capital and that forces the mass to go
into slavery to go into debt which is
what's happening in America today. The
problem with this is that everyone
everyone wants to be part of the elite
and there are too many elite over time.
Okay. So even though you have elite have
many many kids the uh power is a zero
sum game it's a hierarchy and so this
leads to the idea of elite over
production okay elite over production
this is a term um coined by the
historian Peter Turin okay and his
theory is that you have turmoil you have
wars
for example the French revolution for
example uh the follow the woman Roman
Republic because there's too many elite
and they start wars to accumulate power
for themselves.
Okay. So this organization, this elite
leads to basically factionalism or
infighting.
And that's what's happening in America
today where the Democrats and the
Republicans they hate each other. They
refuse to get along.
It leads to political polarization.
Okay. So another saying this is that an
empire over time becomes insular. They
don't care about what happens outside
the world. All they care about is what
happens in Washington DC
and as a result um they make a lot of
stupid mistakes. Okay. All right. Now
last thing is death. Okay. The problem
with death is that if there are no
consequences to your actions, you become
arrogant, you become lazy,
uh, and you become incompetent. Okay?
Because you don't care. It doesn't
really matter. This leads to the idea of
hubris.
Okay? Hubris is just blindness to your
own arrogance. a violent arrogance that
makes you make silly mistakes, but you
don't recognize your mistakes and you
keep on repeating the same mistakes over
and over again, right? So yes, it seems
like the empire is invincible, but if
you actually think about it, the empire
its advantages becomes over time its
disadvantages which will lead ultimately
to its downfall.
Okay. So the mass leads to inequality.
The organization leads to o over
production which leads to factionalism.
And death leads to hubris. That's why an
empire must fall over time.
But an empire cannot fall by itself. It
needs an enemy that forces it to
collapse. Okay? And so what happens is
that an enemy will emerge that will um
overwhelm the empire because it is able
to take advantage of the weaknesses of
the empire, right? And so what are the
weaknesses of this empire? Well, the
first major weakness of this empire is
that the people aren't really motivated.
So if you as people are really
motivated, you have a huge advantage.
Okay, we call this energy. Right
now as an organ as an empire you become
insular. You refuse to omit your
mistakes. You refuse to learn from
others.
Well, if you are willing to omit your
mistakes, if you're willing to learn, if
you're willing to um promote the best
and brightest, if you're willing to
meritocratic, you have a huge advantage.
Okay? And so this idea of openness
Now the last idea is this an empire it's
fractured. So if you're able to m
maintain cohesion
if people are able to remain united if
they're able to have a common purpose
they'll be strong. Okay. So if an enemy
of the empire emerges with these three
qualities energy openness and cohesion
this enemy will defeat the empire.
It doesn't make sense. Okay. So, what I
want you to focus on as you follow the
news in this war between United States
and Iran is ask yourself a question.
Will Iran become an energetic, open, and
cohesive society? Because if it does, it
will become invincible.
The empire won't change because of
hubris. It's too static. It's too
stagnant. It's too bureaucratic. So, the
empire won't change. the empire will not
omit its own mistakes.
And quite honestly, Iran because it's a
it's a still a country of 92 million
people. It still suffers from issues of
mass organization and death.
And so if it's able to transform itself
into an energetic, open co society, then
it will triumph over America. That is
the fundamental question in this war.
Okay? Don't worry about America, its
technology.
Don't worry about the economy. Don't
worry about these things. Okay? Just wor
ask yourself one question. Is Iran
transforming as a society? Are people
becoming much more motivated.
Are people in Iran learning from their
mistakes and innovating and becoming
resilient on the battlefield?
Are the Iranians sticking together as a
people? Okay, because if the answer is
yes to all three questions, then Iran
will win and America will lose. Okay,
doesn't make sense? All right, so that's
just a theory. So let's um let's now
[clears throat]
talk specifically about
America and Iran. Okay. So, America
will have three major advantages
in this war. Okay. These three
advantages are are of course technology,
propaganda,
and money, wealth.
These are the three major strengths of
the American empire. All
right. Technology is just what you see
every day, right? The satellites that
are able to position target these
airplanes that are the greatest war
machines in the world. Okay. So, America
is home to the greatest scientists, the
most advanced weaponry. Okay. That's
just technology.
Propaganda means that America controls
information space. It controls the
internet. It controls the world's most
powerful media including the New York
Times, CNN, BBC.
It controls YouTube. It controls Google.
It controls information landscape.
America does not want you to know
something. It can hide it from you.
America can control the discourse. It
can control how you think about the
world. That's propaganda. The last thing
is money. Okay. And it's very simple
idea. The United States controls the US
dollar which is a s which is the reserve
currency of the world. And the United
States can print as much as much US
dollars as it needs in order to win this
war. It has an infinite money printer.
Okay. And now and then it can use this
uh money to bribe people to fight this
war. Right. It can it can pay for
mercenaries. It can bribe ethnic
minorities to rebel against the
government in Iran. It can bribe Iranian
officials to betray the the government.
Okay.
So looking at these three things, you
would think that America is invincible,
right? But again, we need to think about
the laws asymmetry and recognize that
these advantages are also disadvantages.
All right? So let's discuss this
technology.
Well, you know, if you have the most
advanced weaponry in the world, you
become lazy, arrogant and dependent on
the technology, right? So the classic
example of course is our school where
you have access to chat GPT,
right? And like you become smarter
because you have access to G chat GPT.
No, you become dumber because you become
lazy,
right? Same with technology. You would
think that with the most advanced
weaponry in the world, America will
become invincible. But instead, people
become the American um military becomes
too dependent on the on the technology.
It becomes too arrogant, too complacent.
Okay? It's like, well, you know, if we
if we get in trouble, then we'll just
send in the Air Force and blow
everything up. Okay? So it leads to
dependency
and this actually hampers innovation and
resilience in the battlefield
and this is what you need to win. Okay,
you need to be innovative and you need
to be resilient on the battlefield but
because of technology
you become too lazy
to think for yourself.
All right, so that's one problem.
propaganda. You would think that, oh,
America, America control the debate,
therefore that's a huge advantage. It's
actually not an advantage, guys. The
reason why is that in order for
innovation and resilience to happen, you
need you need to have open debate,
right? You need people to voice
dissenting
opinions.
But if you control the information
landscape, what you can do is sensor.
And that's what America's doing right
now. It's telling people to shut up and
obey. You're not allowed to point out
that this war is stupid and America
can't win this war. Otherwise, you'll be
kicked out. Okay?
So, this means that there's really a
lack of rigorous debate within the
American government, within the American
military, with the American elite, which
of course will lead to hubris. It will
lead to bad decision-m. No one's no one
will point this out because too they're
too afraid of pissing off the president
and his people. So just shut up and
America will keep on making the same
mistakes over and over again. Okay.
We call this drink drinking your own
cool way. Okay.
Okay. They're basically getting high on
on their own supply is another phrase
that that we use. All right. Money and
wealth. Yeah. You would think, okay,
well that's THIS IS THIS IS IT, MAN. We
just brought everyone. We just brought
the entire world and uh we're good,
right? The problem is this. The problem
is that if you bribe people,
they're not going to fight for you,
right? Because all they all they want is
your money. So you bribe them, but then
but they'll probably take your money and
run away.
Okay? Or they'll figure out how to get
more money out of you by cheating you.
So, right now, the Americans are going
to fund these uh militias and ethnic
minorities and opposition groups against
Iran. Okay? Guess what, guys? These guys
are hustlers,
right? They're not fighting because um
they want more freedom. They're fighting
because they want to rip off the US
government.
And so this money issue can be a problem
in the long term because the people
you're bribing you can't even trust and
they're not that motivated to actually
win this war for you. They're actually
motivated to to scam you as much as
possible and they could be actually a
problem in the long term because you're
putting so much resources into these
hustlers. Okay. All right. So
what this means is that America has
three major problems. Okay, it has three
major problems. The first major problem
is
the lack of political will.
And all this is saying is that the
American people don't want to fight this
war.
The American government doesn't even
know why they're fighting this war. No
one cares. Okay? But for the Iranians,
it's a struggle of life and death,
right? If America loses this war, they
just go home and forget about it. But
the Iranians lose this war, they all get
killed or they lose their country, they
lose their society, they lose their
civilization, they lose identity. They
cannot afford to lose this war. Okay. So
the first major problem that Americans
are facing is they don't have any
political will to fight this war but
they're still fighting this war anyway.
Okay. The question of course is why why
why is this happening? This is actually
the most important question and the most
complicated. So so so we'll save this
for later. Okay. Second is the idea of
logistics and manufacturing.
So, America is very good at fighting
short wars. Okay. The reason why is
they're advanced. They have the most
advanced weaponry, but they have
manufacturing issues because as we know,
America ship all its factories to China.
So, America doesn't have that many
factories. So, yes, it has most advanced
weaponry in the world. But this weapon
doesn't doesn't do any good if you don't
have any ammunitions, right? you don't
have any munitions, bombs, bullets, and
you need factories for that. America
doesn't really have these factories.
Now, I understand that America is trying
to is trying to upgrade its
manufacturing capacity, but it's kind of
slow. All right. So, maybe 5 years from
now, it will have manufacturing capac
capacity to fight this war, but right
now it doesn't. So, that's so that's
another
um major issue. Okay. And then and then
the last issue of course is
casualties.
All right. America because it doesn't
have the political will to fight this
war cannot afford to lose soldiers on
the battlefield.
All right. So
it wants to minimize the death. It was
minimized battlefield losses because if
like a thousand tens of thousands of
American soldiers are going home to
America dead in coffins, I guarantee you
because of lack of political will, the
American people will revolt. You have
protest. You will have um a lot of
violence in the streets. It'll be like
the Vietnam uh era again.
All right. Okay. So,
um, yes, I understand that America has
technology, propaganda, and money, but
as we discussed, these aren't really
advantages. And these disadvantages are
huge. The lack of political will, the
lack of manufacturing, and the um lack
of um of America cannot afford to lose
that many soldiers in the battlefield.
Okay? And so this this situation now
determines how America will fight this
war. And we'll discuss this later on.
Okay. All right. Now, let's about
[clears throat]
Okay. [clears throat] So, a ran has a
lot of disadvantages. Okay. But I I I
want to discuss right now there are
three major advantages that they need to
emphasize if they are to survive this
war. All right. The first is the idea of
faith.
All right. So remember that the Iranians
are Shia
and as such it's a religion of martyrdom
of esquetology
of individual sacrifice for the greater
good.
The Shia are not afraid to die. And
because their great religious leader,
the Alatona Kinai was assassinated by
the Americans and Israelis, they are
motivated to seek vengeance, to martyr
themselves for the greater good, to seek
eternal uh paradise. Okay, jihad.
All right, that's the first major
advantage. The second major advantage is
terrain. [clears throat]
And all this means is that
[clears throat]
Iran is a mountainous
country and it's huge. It's three times
the size of Iraq. Um, so it's very hard
for America to invade the country. In
fact, most analysts will will say will
tell you it is suicidal for the American
military to invade uh Iran. It is a
mountain fortress. Okay, it's a
fortress.
And the last issue is the last event is
nationalism.
Okay.
All right. [clears throat]
So, the Iranians are Persians
and the Persians go back 5,000 years. It
is one of the greatest civilizations
in human history. And as we discussed
last semester in the ancient world,
there were three great civilizations,
right? The Jews, the Greeks, and the
Persians.
And u the Persian culture, it's vast,
it's beautiful, and it's deep. And
that's what gives the Iranian people a
lot of pride.
Okay? So when they're fighting, they're
not just fighting for the religion, not
just fighting for the homes, they're
fighting for the entire civilization
that goes back 5,000 years. Right? So
these are the three major advantages
that the Iranians have. Okay? Fate means
that they're not afraid to die for what
they believe in. Terrain means that the
Americans who have a hard problem
invading the country. Uh nationalism
means that the people of Iran know what
they're fighting for.
All right. So, but again remember ebing
that it seems like an advantage can be a
disadvantage as well. All right. So,
[clears throat]
let's go over what the problems are with
faith. You might have an issue of
blindness.
Okay. or zealatry
where you're not afraid to die,
but that means that you're not thinking
strategically. Okay? Maybe you're going
to waste too many soldiers on the
battlefield. They're brave, but they're
kind of stupid as well. All right? So
you might have an issue where Iran is
not using the optimal um strategy
because [clears throat] their soldiers
are not afraid of death. And we're
already seeing that where the Americans
have already blown up and destroyed the
Iranian navy. Now any told you that the
first thing Americans would do is go
destroy the Iranian navy. So you should
probably not use the navy or hide the
navy or blow up the navy yourself. Okay?
because you want to avoid as many
casualties as possible. But they didn't
do that and they and the Americans have
now destroyed the Iranian navy. All
right? So that's the issue of faith
terrain. Yeah, it's a fortress but it
can also be a prison, right? Where
you're just sort of stuck there and
because it's a mountainous region, it
doesn't have that many resources. So
Americans can actually disrupt your
water supply, disrupt your electricity,
okay, and cause general poverty and
hardship for your people. Okay? And then
nationalism. Yes, Persia is a great
culture, but remember that Iran is a
ethnically diverse country. In fact,
only 50% of the population of Iran are
Persians. Others are different
minorities. Okay. All right. So, um you
have then ethnic
divisions,
right?
Okay. So, looking at this now, we know
exactly
what the American strategy will be.
Basically, the strategy will be to
inflict
as many casualties as possible on the
Iranians.
All right? To kill as many people as
possible,
destroy the infrastructure of Iran of
Iran so that the people don't have
enough water, electricity, food to
survive. Okay? And the third of course
is to create as much ethnic tension in
the country as possible by arming and
encouraging and bribing ethnic groups to
rebel against central government in
Tran. Right?
Okay. But again,
what the law of symmetry, asymmetry
tells us is that the empire ultimately
is not as flexible and open and dynamic
as its enemy. Okay? The weaker person is
going to engage in much more
self-reflection,
self-debate
than the empire. Okay? Because empire
will become arrogant. And so ultimately
Iran should triumph over America. And in
fact, what's going to happen is that
this strategy that America will use
against the Iranians will lead to
Iranians becoming much more energetic,
open, and cohesive.
Okay. So let's look at let's look at
let's look at American strategy
specifically.
H. [clears throat]
All right. So, this is an ethnic map of
Iran. Okay. Now, certain things that you
will see is how divide the country is.
Yeah. The Persians are in the center,
but people you want to watch are the
Kurds. Okay. The Kurds and the um
Azaris.
and the bollocks.
Okay, these are the three major problem
areas for Iran and it's always been the
case. Remember the Persians are in the
middle. So the Bllocks are first of all
Sunni Muslims.
As we discussed last class, the Sunnis
and the Shia have never really gotten
along well together. They have different
I mean the same religion uh Islam but
they have different belief systems
that's led to a lot of conflicts in the
past. It's almost like the Catholics and
the Protestants. Okay. And so the Bulock
have been trying to rebel against
Iranians for a long time. I guarantee
you that there are already Israeli and
American special forces embedded in this
area. Okay. The reason why is that they
want to encourage as much civil conflict
as possible, but they also want to
prepare the graph the possibility for a
ground invasion of America. Okay. So,
they would need a um [clears throat]
forward operating base and this area
could be a very good place for a
beginning of a land of of a land
invasion. Then you over here you have
the Kurds. Okay. The Kurds are another
minority that seeks national
sovereignty.
And right now what's happening is that
the Americans and Israelis are bombing
this area heavily and they're targeting
police stations. Why? Because they're
trying to reduce and eliminate
opposition so that they can arm the
Kurds and have them come into this area
and and threaten um Iran. What's also
happening is that in Iraq
there are these Sunni
uh groups, okay, that the Americans are
uh basically bribing
and arming and they're basically
fanatics, okay? They're ISIS and what
the Americans want to do is send them
into uh Iran to cause as much problem as
possible. Okay. Then you over here you
have Azaran.
Abrajan.
It is a independent country. What's
really odd is that the majority of
ethnic uh Azaris are actually in Iran.
60 6% are in the country 40% are in the
country of Azaran. Which means that from
the perspective of the Arabian people,
this war could be an opportunity to
reunite
the people, okay, and create a greater
Azure. So these are the three problem
areas that you have to watch as this war
develops over the next few weeks, over
the next few months. Okay. So we already
know what the American strategy will be
because we've seen it in Libya, in Syria
before. Okay. So what is the strategy?
All right. So again, the strategy is to
both attack without, okay, from outside
and inside as well. So what you're going
to do is this. You're going to arm these
people in em inbed special forces into
these inserting groups to lead them and
provide air cover so they have a clear
path into Iran and are able to eliminate
opposition. Okay. All right. So now
you're attacking from without
attacking from within means to cause as
much pain and suffering in the interior
of Iran as possible. All right. And how
do you do that? Well, you do that
through um decapitation. Okay, let's go
over the strategies.
Okay, decap decap decapitation.
Okay, and what you're doing is you're
removing
the elite,
okay? Or what we call command and
control.
Okay, you're basically limiting the
capacity of Iran to govern itself, to
have a leadership, to have an elite,
right? Command and control. Okay, so
that's the first strategy. Second
strategy
is um
um area of environment, okay,
aerosmreacy.
>> [clears throat]
>> So again, America has the most advanced
airplanes in the world. And the way that
it's using its airplanes is to destroy
as much military installation as
possible, but it's also engaging in acts
of sabotage. Okay? So what they're doing
is they're cover bombing.
Okay? So they're carpet bombing Tran.
Okay?
um they're doing soft targeting.
Soft targeting. Soft targeting means
that instead of attacking military
installations, you attack hospitals.
Why? Because you're degrading the
capacities uh sorry, you're degrading
the state's capacity to rejuvenate
itself to be resilient. Okay. The last
thing is something called double tap.
Double tap is this. Okay. Uh and it's
really illegal uh or against um
international law. What you do is this.
You attack a place, right? You kill some
people and then people try to come and
help the people who are injured and it
could be like um doctors, it could be
emergency emergency personnel, it could
be relatives, right? And then you strike
again to create as much as many civilian
casualties as possible, right? And the
entire idea is to create as much fear
and anxiety in people as possible so
that they lose the capacity to resist.
All right. And [snorts] the last thing
you do um [clears throat] and so the and
the last thing of course is to um arm
and bribe [clears throat]
insurgents.
Okay. So these are the three main
pillars of the American strategy and you
will see this over the next few weeks.
The problem [clears throat]
with this is that when you do these
three things, you're not actually
hurting the Iranians, you're actually
helping them. Because remember the law
of asymmetry states that whichever group
is able to to create energy, openness,
and cohesion will win. And guess what
guys,
this American strategy is going to
create a more energetic, more open and
more cohesive
person society. All right, let me show
you how. All right, the decapitation.
We just said that one major problem for
America is elite over production, right?
Well, with the countation,
what you're doing is you're solving this
problem for the Iranians, right? Before
the huge problem for the Iranians were,
you have too many leaders
and they all have their own stupid
opinion and they all want to lead this
war, right? But by killing so many
leaders, you allow
for more mobility, for more for more
meritocracy, right? you're solving the
problem of over production for the
radiance. That's a huge huge bonus guys.
Okay. So, um the leadership will become
much more lean, much more mean, much
more determined and much more strategic.
Okay, that's number one. Number two,
aeros supremacy.
Well, when you do this to people, when
you cover bomb tan, you're creating a
more cohesive society.
Why? Because the major conflict in Iran
for many decades was the conflict
between the urban areas and the rural
areas. The rural areas were very
religious, very poor, very backward. And
the urban areas were educated, secular
and progressive. Okay? And so there's
this huge conflict that led to a lot of
riots, a lot of protests in uh Iran. But
when you cover ball the cities which are
the main source of of of support for you
know progressive western policies you
make them united with the rural areas.
Okay does that make sense? The Iranian
people no longer see themsel each other
as enemies. They see the Americans as
enemies. You create a much more cohesive
society which are who are willing to
fight together and that's a problem.
Okay. All right. The last thing you Yes,
you are arming the insurgents, the
bulocks, the Kurds, the Zaris. Okay,
that's fine. The problem with this is
that you are now
activating, galvanizing Persian
nationalism,
right?
For the longest time, the Persian
national identity was suppressed by the
theocracy because they want to create a
more, you know, they want to create a
grand religion that unites all
ethnicities. When you turn the other
minorities against the Iranians, then
the Persian people have to come together
and remember their history, celebrate
their identity. And this is the key,
okay? Once the Persian people are able
to activate their long-lasting memories,
go back in the past and remember the
greatness, they come together as an
energetic, open, and cohesive society.
Okay?
So, yes, the Americans have this
strategy that worked in Libya and Syria
and other places, but it's not going to
work in Iran. In fact, it's going to do
the opposite in
Iran.
Okay. And then you're like, well, why
don't the Americans not do this? And I
already told you because it's an empire,
okay? It doesn't care about Iran. It
cares about itself. And so, it's sort of
stuck with this policy because remember,
it's trying to win this war as quickly
as possible because it doesn't have the
manufactured capacity to fight this war
for a long time. It's trying to reduce
as many civilian cas sorry. It's trying
to reduce as many casualties among its
soldiers as possible because the
Americans don't have the political will
to fight this war. America is trying to
win this war cheaply and fast. If it
doesn't, then Americans in a lot of
trouble. Okay, does that make sense,
guys? All right, let me now
um conclude or sorry, let let me now
discuss the Iranian strategy. Okay. So,
um, what the Americans are using is a
classic strategy called siege warfare.
Okay.
And so, what the Iranians are going to
do is they're going to respond with a
classic strategy called guerilla
warfare.
Okay? And gorilla warfare, guys, it's
just simple. Hide and seek.
All right? So, you come bomb me with all
everything you have, I'll just hide in
my mountains. And then when you leave,
what what I'm going to do? I'm going to
attack your uh GCC countries. I'm going
to lob drones, rockets at you. I'm I'm
lo um rockets at Israel, okay? I I I
don't have I don't have to strike that
hard. I just have to make I just have to
be a pain in the ass, okay? Because then
what happens is you're forced to come
back and bomb the living hell out of me.
But guess what? I was hide my mouth
again. It's hide and seek. Okay? So Iran
can do this for years and years and
years. But again, remember America is
forced to win this war as fast as
possible because there is no political
will. They don't have much manufacturing
capacity and they uh don't want to uh
they don't want that many casualties and
economic damage. Okay? Does that make
sense, guys? All right. So that's all
Iran is going to do. Iran is just going
to be a pain in the ass. Okay? A pain in
the ass. It's trying to create as much
economic damage as possible. is trying
to create as much fear as possible,
right? Which will force America to
attack. The grand question is this,
will America launch a ground invasion?
Okay? Because if it does,
then
um they've lost the war. Okay? All
right. Because look look at look at
Iran. Okay? Mountains and mountains,
deserts. It is impossible to occupy this
country.
All right. It is impossible to invade.
And what they want to do is be so such a
pain in the ass to commit so much guilt
warfare that America is forced to
invade. Okay. from over here and from
over here and from over here and from
over here and then eventually uh but the
problem is that America doesn't h does
not have the resources the political
will the manufacturing capacity to fight
this war okay doesn't make sense right
so now you're like okay I understand all
this but why the hell is this war
happening then
if I can tell you this okay I'm sure
that their generals can tell them this
as well I'm sure that they know that
this was the case. In fact, for years,
America has been planning to invade
Iran. And for years, the general was
like, "No, that's suicidal. Let's not do
this." Okay. So, why is this happening?
And unfortunately, we don't know because
the administration is not telling us. At
first, Trump is like, "Oh, because the
nuclear talks didn't go well." We know
for a fact that the Iranians were
willing to agree to all terms of the
Americans.
And then Marco Rubio, who's who's the
secretary of state, he came out
yesterday. He he said something really
moronic. He said that why did we attack
Iran? Because we heard the Israelis were
going to attack first. Then Iranians
were going to respond by by attacking
both the Israelis and us, the Americans.
And therefore, we have to preempt this
really by attacking first. That's just
Okay. Right. So, they don't
they don't know why they're doing this.
But there has to be a reason, right?
Okay. Well, a clue is this. A clue is
this. The soldiers are being asked, the
American soldiers are being asked to
fight this war. And again, no one knows
why this war is happening, but there's
reporting that the generals are telling
the soldiers, "This is a war
for
Jesus.
This is a war
to
create the second coming of Jesus."
Okay, this is um John Larson and he's
writing this on on selfstack. Okay, US
troops were told Iran war is for
Armagen, the return of Jesus. What is
this? All right. So, um, so sorry. So,
um,
some soldiers who are not Christians
were told that there's a war for Jesus
and like, wait a minute, we're not we're
not Christians. We're Muslims or we're
atheists. Why are we fighting this war?
And so, they file complaint about this
speech. Okay. and we're going to read a
part of this email that the soldiers who
are desenting sent to some other people
to complain about this. Okay. So, um I
could could you read please?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> I am a NCO rank withheld in our unit.
This morning, our commander opened up
the combat readiness status briefing by
urging us to not be afraid as to what is
happening with our combat operations in
Iran right now.
>> Stop. Okay. Afraid. That's what it tells
us they're losing the war.
>> Okay. Right. Keep on going.
>> He urged us to tell our troops that this
was all part of God's divine plan. And
he specifically
>> Wait a minute here. Wait a minute. God's
divine plan. God's not the one ordering
them to fight this war. It's Trump or or
the American military. Okay, this is
kind of weird. Keep on going. And he
specifically referenced numerous
citations out of the book of Revelation
referring to Armageddon and the imminent
return of Jesus Christ. He said that
President Trump has been anointed by
Jesus to light the signal fire in Iran
to cause Armageddon and mark his return
to earth.
>> Oh my god. President Trump, the fire in
Iran, it's all part of a grand plan to
destroy the world so that Jesus will
return. What is this craft? Okay, keep
on going.
>> He had a big grin on his fa on his face.
>> He's happy about this, guys. THE WORLD
IS ENDING. YEAH, [screaming]
KEEP ON GOING.
>> When he said all of this, which made his
message seem even more crazy, our
commander would probably be described as
a Christian first supporter. He has been
this way for a very long time and makes
it clear that he desires all of us under
him to become just like him as a
Christian. But what he did this morning
was so toxic and over the line that it
shocked many of us in attendance at the
ops reinous brief briefing. Beside
besides myself, I am reaching out to
MRFF on behalf of 15 fellow troops. I
know you asked me about the religious
views of our group who has requested
help from the MRFF. I can only tell you
that I am Christian and at least 10 of
the others are also Christians. One of
the others is Jewish and one is one is
Muslim. I don't know the religious or
non-religious status for the other three
at this time.
>> Okay. So, what is happening is that
there are some crazy Christians in the
American military in American
government, okay, that want to use this
war
to end the world
to force Jesus to return.
That is why this war is happening. Okay?
I'm not saying I'm not saying that this
is a reason why, but I'm saying like
this is a possibility, okay? All right.
This is Trump and these all religious
leaders that support Trump because they
see him as Messiah. They they see him as
this as this great hero who will cause
the time of Christianity and the return
of Jesus. [music] And that's a
possibility as to why this war is being
fought. Okay? Because quite honestly,
there's no other reason. It's hard for
me to come up with another reason. Okay.
All right. So, this is something that we
will look at as we go along. What is
this crap? What is Christian Zionism?
Why would they think that this war in
the Middle East will cause the return of
Jesus? Okay, we'll we'll discuss this
later on.
But I wanted to but now it leads us to
another problem which is our entire
class is on game theory. Right guys,
this is kind of weird because [snorts]
what this suggests is that religion
[applause]
is more important. Okay, so what's the
point of game theory if people don't
play by game theory? If all if they're
just religious fanatics.
All right, and the answer is this. And
the answer is
it's still game theory. But the problem
is that
what you think
of the game that you think they're
playing is not the game they're playing.
The reward that you think they want want
is not the reward they that they want.
Okay? We think in terms of material
things. Okay? So money, resources,
power, we think that the war is being
fought over these things
and it's not.
All right. The grand secret, the grand
reveal all the semester, all this course
is this. The real power, the real
currency in the world is not money.
It is human consciousness
or basically attention.
Okay, this is this is it guys. Okay,
once you understand this idea, you
understand everything. But this is a
hard idea to understand. So So I I'll
need some time to actually explain this.
All right.
This war is being fought to control the
consciousness of the human race because
it is our consciousness that creates
reality itself. That's the source of all
wealth and all power in this world.
Okay, that's why this is happening. In
other words, this is a war not just for
Iran. This is a war not just for the
Middle East. It is a war for the soul of
humanity. This is what's happening,
guys. All right? This is what World War
II is. World War II is meant to be the
last and final war of all human history.
Because whoever win this war will
control the very soul of human existence
for all of eternity. Okay? That is the
end game.
And I know this is a hard idea to
understand. But as we go along, I will
explain this to you. Okay? That is the
grand secret behind the world.
Everything that you believe, everything
that you see today, it's all an
illusion.
The reality, the truth is that
consciousness is a source of all power
of reality itself. And so this is a war
for human consciousness. It's a war for
the very soul of humanity.
Okay, any questions?
All right, I I will see you guys next
week.